hey guys and welcome to nerding out the
show where us gamespot nerds and you
talk about the things that we like and
today we're talking about agents of
shield winter finale laws of Inferno
dynamics
[Music]
you know what's hot like fire that Ghost
Rider that it goes right is Right girls
tried it can we talk about how
ridiculous that's seen with Robbie and
Eli was and how it was just weekend so
obvious it's like oh let me stand then
this box nothing could go wrong here oh
no I've been stabbed through with the
friggin shoulder by my uncle again why
did I stand in this is a wily coyote
back me box series mac me on the side
the plate of bird seeds I don't know why
couldn't just like step step off ghost
rider yeah just go like I don't know and
how did he not how could he not flame on
with was getting stabbed that I didn't
know that that happened no unless I mean
if he's so much pain that he couldn't
focus on changing [ __ ] obviously dead
he was dead twice God did he got dead
twice right there I dead or no I so much
debtors oh I wonder if it's because of
jumping ahead a little bit where the
carbon spike the matter was coming from
that maybe that could be some Thai to
prevent I don't know it was make any
sense be that or could be a plot hole
well probably never know we'll find out
no we won't maybe not ever but you know
what the demon core is real mm-hmm the
demon core is real it's real tell me
about it buddy so we looked it up uh the
demon core was originally used for
testing in operation crossroads which
was basically when they blew up bikini
atoll um I'm saying that right right
right nerds I'm saying at all that's all
bikini at all um I don't know so a bunch
of scientists this thing was originally
called Rufus and it was Miss of course a
core of of highly you know that stuff
irradiated stuff are not irradiated but
like I don't know radium or plutonium or
something like that but the lid thing
was was a real mechanic in this thing so
sometimes scientists would to perform
this like experiment they would need to
like slightly charge this thing so they
would use a screwdriver to keep the lid
separated from the core and twice one
time a guy was just being a cowboy
literally work
cowboy boots and the the the the
screwdriver slipped and the thing
touched and he became irradiated but he
protected all of his buddies died of
radiation poisoning like 20 days later
yes it happened twice so they renamed
died twice no no another scientist same
same thing that guy died twice just like
ghost rider yeah that's right weird his
head lit a fire and his uncle sucked so
they renamed it from Rufus to the demon
core and now we have a plot device I
think its braid oh very nice so last
week we talked about molecule man mm-hmm
so Eli was causing all these earthquakes
what was going on there so yeah he's
create you know his whole thing is I was
creating things from nothing which that
that's molecule man doesn't really
create things he manipulates stuff like
that so he either I wasn't doing that he
was a thought he was creating from
nothing but it turned out he wasn't so
there could be kind of a molecule man
tweaked you know throwback or maybe not
maybe so it was like molecule man and
his entire existence never caused
earthquakes right yeah so they needed
something to do with quake they brought
that whole thing in and now we have a
cool thing for quick to do great yeah
and speaking of her she was able to
absorb the earthquakes so we just had
Chloe Bennet standing in a room while
like eight is doing this and it Chloe's
like uh again no it's too much not that
is this the first time that we've seen
her absorbing earthquakes I guess
there's a question is she absorbing it
or did when did Fitz tweak her gauntlet
so much what fry not the case cuz she
must be in tune to it absorption plates
frequency mines and then something
processing unit something processing
units when he's talking about her new
their new godless they're so fresh and
so clean yeah was weird uh so she could
be actually absorbing I think it could
be buying activity she's she's still
relatively new with her powers and she
hasn't had him that lying so it's
possible she could be growing the more
she uses them you know the the more
intense it becomes yeah I i wonder how
strong
how powerful could she be like if she
because those gauntlets are basically
power inhibitors yeah you know otherwise
her bones are just gonna shatter and
their their absorption for all the
seismic activity because she's created
in her hand she did say that she was
feeling like one-tenth the power oh
really yeah ooh didn't she that pretty
sure she said that oh so it to me I took
it as it sits containing her power so
when she's using it it's not so intense
it's like right it's just like a little
bit since I don't like this she's got
shocks on her arm thats Sarah powerful
is she then that's things she's like
crack the earth I think that we should
just get some get some adamantium or
something in those just get your bones
adamantium bones yes yeah I never worry
about it just know what careful there
might vibrate her skin do an adamantium
dip like get a nurse but dipper had a
man came to my fox though no Kevin it's
cool cool you know what's cool about him
he's got all that about that my brain
iam though the things you need a healing
factor in order to get you know stuff
injected into you because it's gonna
kind of hurt you still go dude the
licensing knowledge that you contain in
your brain isn't him it's an ADA brain
beta ray so we saw in this episode there
was a scene where Daisy's talking to
Coulson and he makes a joke about he how
he wanted her to be the face of shields
and she's like maybe in the comic books
so in the comic books what is Daisy's
role is she like a leader or face of
shield so she kind of came out of
nowhere where she was like introduced
she's like 18 should level 10 clearance
which is the highest clearance possible
so she had access to everything and she
was basically Nick Furies price student
and Nick Fury did some questionable
things so he was kind of on you know on
a run and hiding and then that's where
the secret warriors came about and she
was like the leader of that so I don't
think she was really ever leading shield
because like Maria Hill has taken on
that role but she was definitely super
high clearance and why I still don't
know how she got that clearance yeah I
don't either maybe maybe uh
[Music]
maybe she was up to something nefarious
they just she was just super cool she's
like 19 year old Winston kidnap she
hacked her way in she just packed her
own clearance she was a creepy van
hacker for a little while and now swim
let us not forget look at her now she's
leveled blue now she's level blue that
means let's talk about 80 for a second
so she was like I don't use magic magic
magic involves deception yeah yeah so
what's up what's up with that so magic
does magic exists here or does it not
there's two questions like okay is Etta
actually capable of lying because if
she's capable of lying but she is using
magic well she's obviously using magic
but is she easily miss a second thing if
magic is is more of a thing so maybe
she's like no magic isn't real i'm using
science science or maybe she is using
magic and she could have been programmed
to lie rah or maybe she programmed
herself maybe she could tweak herself
after gym she's making a brain she can
make adjustments to herself drunken we
gotta get her some help so we don't know
i mean yeah cuz we saw that she was
programmed to feel pain which sucked
that was really really westworld be like
yeah that was strange yeah I ever not
how you and they're like Sorry Sorry
good thanks but sorry yep also let's
talk about mace really quick so we saw
him in his gear Patriot gear perhaps
yeah lose shield no he's having a fight
he's been waiting yeah he had it in his
closet ready to break you like all right
like this is a time oh look what I have
oh I've got this really sweet costume
over here boy yeah so he was called
Patriot in the comics so it's not
necessarily red white and blue to be too
close to Captain America which there's
connections there but so yeah if he
starts wearing the question is is he
gonna be wearing that more often because
he's always wearing a simple right or is
it you know the directors not supposed
to be on the field but we saw Coulson do
that all the time so maybe mace is like
I'm gonna go out and be out there too i
feel like the director should be should
do some facetime or whatever that line
is yeah okay so that made me dislike him
a little bit more and then all of a
sudden he had that heart to heart do we
trust him do you guys still some you
just I trust him you trust him he just
he sat down on that lick thing in the in
the in the hangar and was like listen
Coulson I don't know what you want from
me dude like I'm trying to do the thing
I mean he wasn't that he wasn't that
whiny but it really got me I believed
that I believed it yeah he had an answer
for everything like why he was working
with the senator all of it and it all
completely making them I just don't know
i mean when when he when he finds out
about ada you know he's he's a little
freaked out at first that she's an
android cuz he's like I was kind of
tracted to her he totally checked her
out but then he's like will let world
dissector later whatever you know so he
tells radcliffe you know bring all your
research here and you know so basically
so we can control cuz he he was upset
he's like get you guys learn anything
from Ultron oh yeah he's like that's
what she asked for but it's it's like
why does does he want ada there because
one he's creepily attracted to her Jabba
to the same roof he wants he wants to
observe oh you know me maintain make
sure everything's safe and secure or
three does he have some other plans what
they could use I I'm in theory something
else I'm in between here I don't trust
him completely but I think that you know
he he does care about the team he cares
about the team but he might have his own
agenda yeah especially when when the
news was talking and he's he was upset
about his his face what do you call a
head shot who knows a slight hitch
though sure wendy was upset about that
wasn't as good site so it's like he's so
concerned about that and the fact that
he's got this fancy costume so it is it
an ego thing or is it there's more
layers mean he might just be really a
lot a lot better at marketing than
Coulson you know yeah although that dude
that died his little his little buddy
his little assistant that was like yeah
you're right sir that is your bad side I
was like that dudes dead that dude so
good is a red shirt monday was Gabriel
Lunas birthday he just turned 34 a happy
birthday game and now he's off the show
maybe indefinitely you're fired yeah let
ah alright enough of its gone to our
featured theory from one of our viewers
so youtube user fresh j3 said I think
ADA is creating a cyborg son Victor
Manchu anyone can you elaborate on that
Tony so Victor was created by Ultron
hold on so that's obviously debunked
after watching yeah yeah yeah this is in
case it was a good call good theory
because you know we wonder what was ADA
doing right creating other you know was
treating a boyfriend was she was she
doing so so Ultron which ultra did
create Jocasta which was a girlfriend
basically firm with robot weird stuff
I'm glad you see rates Victor and
eventually what you know heat this kid
he was a teen he thought he was a real
kid he finds out he's part robot or
whatever he ends up joining the runaways
which is a group of teens who find out
their parents are super villains they
take off and then end up doing good
things I'll that this would have been a
cool kind of introduction because they
ABC preformed faith lon freeform is
doing a runaway show and they could have
has like here's Viktor mansha and then
now so much oh yeah but they're not
doing that yep boo oh good theory dude
yeah very thanks for sending that in so
let's talk about our nerd chills moments
of last night all right who wants to go
first what was your moment Tony I'm
gonna take it first right guys we pre
discussed Miami leads into yours a bit
so the yo-yo thing where she like like
Coulson sticks out his hand and then she
like flips his gun around and like then
he just pulls the trigger max freakin
shotgun blade thing all that was so do
very well coordinate ously yeah that's
what I wanted but go go so yo-yos
running super fast and in a blink of an
eye yeah and you know so if this dude is
holding a gun up to Coulson and she
grabs it and that split-second puts it
in his hand it is going so fast discuss
it's like if you get like the ultimate
high five to just stings your makes your
Hannah bread it's dumb the instantaneous
momentum of something maybe because also
it didn't talk you and cannot move that
fast anyway so all we talking about is
the is
is theory anyways an inhuman so I know
that I know that it's a completely
different you know comic but all the
speedsters in DC would be completely
dead like all of them would they would
have killed many yeah I remember
something I don't know if it wasn't a
flash or sounds like that where someone
was like running with someone and they
held him by the back of her neck so it
wouldn't get whiplash well that makes
sense so I don't know if it was in the
flasher frozen something else but but if
you stop something perfectly in time
like if they threw it in speed that
would do something but if you just set
something somewhere like she's not like
whipping but still it's still going from
from here to here in that split second
everybody what do you think is rachel is
right it's it's theoretical physicists
out there just I like like if I threw a
pennant do I pass a cubed what was your
nerd chills moment looks like you're
chill moment your nerd till moment I
don't even remember my here you were
talking about the Indian or and a crazy
ending so it's like what the heck is
going on so we see that like the guy to
died he's uses a you know picking up all
the stuff going it's just throwing stuff
in a box not even organizing Radcliffe's
notes he's just like someone else is
gonna sort this out out here and then
you know the closet opens in you I I I
don't know for some reason I thought
there was gonna be like a deformed
shaved dog animal like yes he had a baby
I don't know why is like something you
know like maybe was like some more thing
that she's trying to newark cuz since
she comes with the bowl of water and
says she broke a dude's neck you thought
it was a shave dog know what I thought
it was I thought of some Creek is he's
like oh yeah he was shocked by something
and then we find out its agent Melinda
may she's she's unconscious blood but
then we also find out I just spit a
little we goes up by not on me I'll fine
a little bit that at the same time she's
with Coulson about the drink that bottle
is gone
oh it's just a copy of her that she made
she made that really fast yeah by the
way magically how did she make a magic
power gloves she took her magic magic
for joining us something stupid I think
she's I'm sorry Harry Potter fans I'm
really sorry for that or I mean it could
just be since we don't know what the
process of the cube the mold is you know
the jello mold so maybe it's just like
it does something and then she 3d scans
may then they just make the face it
could just be a couple minutes or an
indie make go to hair or something like
that or maybe she had at me maybe she's
got a whole the whole team in the claw
other closets maiya she did and stop it
right now I wonder I what it meant to
the puns on this me what is happening
yeah maybe maybe Radcliffe is a LM deal
so maybe what was your what was your
favorite moment um I was really happy
when Daisy was brought back into the
fold Daisy was made a agent again bye
Mase what that was nice even if it was
just for the cameras she she is now back
with her family where she belongs so
that made me happy yeah and the fact
that she's still like me she's like I
don't really like know about the rules
and work so she's still gonna be the
teen rebel snap teen but Sony lately I'm
not gonna do what you say she's their
residence I mean I like these like the
jewelry but because because obviously
that the team works well when they kind
of go against Authority when you do
there on that that's how they've worked
yeah they break the rules and they get
the job done mm-hmm yep that's your be
their third break the rules and get the
job not cool all right let's talk about
predictions so the show does not come
back until January 10 is that correct
this is true oh alright so until January
10th let's make some predictions about
what we're going to see next month take
it yeah so I think that Robbie's coming
back I don't think we've seen the last
of him would you agree I hope so sure a
shirt on hope so I like that guy
wholesome mixes his line but cuz when he
tells Daisy oh no she's like you think
he's gonna be back and she's not the
first ghost rider it should quiet which
is like back what but the thing is if he
comes back
there's not really a place for him on
the team they can't make him an agent
also we didn't really talk about this
but he is completely indestructible he's
got and obviously like well it's not a
spirit of vengeance that's already been
proven like well I guess it could
potentially be a spirit of vengeance but
he's immortal he's immortal he's
completely uncontrollable it like the
power level on him is insane like he got
stabbed he was dead he got killed in
this episode we didn't even talk about
that like ghost rider being ghost rider
compared to anyone on agents of shield
is like yeah their puny he's him coming
back could potentially be something that
they need to control or need to harness
like he might not come back as something
good because this was his last job where
he's not like if he comes back he's he's
only doing the spirit of vengeance ha's
or whatever is inside of long as it's
not uncle Eli yeah so he's only doing
that thing's bidding there was some
rumbling apparently runny or comic-con
it's like people were saying like oh go
sir I should get his own show we should
get a spinoff so maybe because I as cool
as he has as great as he is and you know
that i love the non romantic chemistry
between him and daisy because you know i
don't i don't think you need a male and
female always like oh let's let's hook
up cuz we're opposite sex or what it was
sup girl my head's on fire so if he does
come back you know it'd be great to have
him come back for more interactions but
he can't be an agent or he's not gonna
get like he won't be any level fire bad
yeah and a badge won't look good on that
was so i get if he got his own show then
he could go out the street to sign your
prediction his own show maybe yeah
what's your prediction i'd say it cuz if
he comes back it's just me he can't
become a regular under cuz there's
there's no place for him what's shield
he's a killer yeah alright buddy what
are you predictions you have some
thoughts on ADA my prediction is about
ADA so it's like there's three options
for what was going on and in my head you
guys can totally tell me if I'm wrong
but so the first two options are eight
is evil ada has become corrupted by the
dark hold well that would be so cliche
and pretty predictable because they need
they need a threat now
Eli's great right we need a villain so 8
is like made a copy of May who's just an
l md an evil elm need to do to do 8 is
bidding you know I don't think that
one's very probable but it's possible
that she's just become blanket statement
evil the second is that the you're gonna
have to pronounce it for Misha thong a
thong the dude who wrote the dark hole
door thing that wrote the dark hold the
power behind the dark hold the purpose
of the dark hold is to get this guy it
released in our plane maybe she was
building that brain and chiffon is now
in may in the lmd may the third option
is a little harder to believe that she's
good but may was corrupted by the dark
hold she was a little bit weird about it
you know she wanted like to use it and
that kind of thing so may was like dude
she's been corrupted by this book I know
what happens when humans like get
corrupted by this book the doctor read
it but he was like dude what is this get
this away from me so it's possible that
she was like I've assess his threat with
this dark hold he doesn't like it but
may he's scarier than the backpack it's
been corrupted by it so I'm gonna get
her replaced figure out what's going on
with her brain meats and then kick her
back out into the team when she's all
better those are my three predictions
and I know it's not direct prediction
it's just kind of theories but I think
one of those might happen and you know
but what do you guys yeah yeah i mean at
first i was like well she's evil and you
know even though it's like I said it's
cliche they mentioned ultra and all that
but I like your idea of maybe she's you
know they want us to think she's evil
because that's the cliffhanger until
January but maybe there's something else
going on yeah let's go to our question
of the week so youtube user go go ask
but seriously though who was the inhuman
guy yeah I don't know we don't know we
have no information on that but reddit
thinks that it is probably grid is that
correct yeah so I mean reddit searches
and then also are like our own personal
search this is basically the only Indian
uh the only hero
indian descent is grid his name is
dinesh deo maybe by the way you can
correct me on that sorry if that the
pronunciation is wrong but basically his
power profile is super strength super
speed but also control over like
electromagnetic whatnot he can control
like you know cybernetic stuff I don't
know if it was him and then like he you
know he emerges as you know a superhero
and inhuman why would he not use his
powers like as you know as soon as he
comes out of the cocoon you didn't know
he doesn't just woke up he's cramped up
he's been like that for seven months a
slow cooker I just wondered what cooking
the fact that he's been cooking for so
long yeah it seems like this could be
the next story arc that we deal with
yeah there's gotta be something seems
like it could be and powerful there's
gotta be something to more than I mean
grid he's a newer character I don't I
don't know if it would be him I mean it
could be but you would think that
there's got to be some big threat I mean
if inhuman if terrigenesis is moments
and he was there seven months there's
got to be something this guy is gonna be
amped up and a big problem or maybe he's
just really slow your he's a moth grid
as a moth you want a butterfly a me how
that but then is Senator nadir because I
think he's her brother then that are not
really clear on that because she was at
his place whatever there's all the mail
and so if if he is her brother and if
she hates in humans is she going to be
able to use him for her evil purposes or
is it gonna be like oh do I got to
change my ways and embrace and humans
yeah that might be what they're doing I
mean it's obvious that Senator anadyr is
is so slightly nefarious and he's in
he's and he's got some problems going on
yeah I find it interesting though that
his DVR is full seven months ances
profit this DVR super full and he was
just this is abby winters house forever
yeah just a lawn ornaments for his evil
sisters for six months or something okay
so there's no more agents of shield
until January tense but before we go I
want to shout out to super blue boy 2010
on YouTube who said just came from the
west-world finale didn't know gamespot
universe existed but I like you guys
some here's
day yeah yeah if you're watching on
gamespot universe great job you did it
thank you so much if you're watching on
gamespot you have to go to gamespot
universe because as of january third all
of our nerding outs are moving there you
can't see them on that channel anymore
so please subscribe to gamespot universe
and for all things nerding out stick
things about universe thank you
[Music]